[Music]
will you tell um well it's a machine
track changing input to know why we
tomorrow yeah so ha if you do not
preserve integrity protect the
spectators don't trust it they're not
gonna come they're not gonna fall in
love with it the passion dies the game
dies
awesome long ago but it hasn't been sunk
in the Gulf no ma'am nothing fine now do
you need this plastic couldn't you use a
pencil to stir your coffee what's wrong
with a pencil let's bring it up to speed
with the violent clashes which have
broken out again
in Hong Kong between pro-democracy
protesters and police this time inside
Hong Kong Airport police entered the
terminal building two were met by
protesters who shot lasers and their
faces at through missiles a number of
protesters were filmed being detained by
those police frustrated protesters then
surrounded a man who they believed to be
an undercover police officer he was
inside a circle of people
his hands were seemed tied with cable
ties
their moves are severe and violence
offenses and already showed signs of a
terrorism central government of China
never allowed a few violent offenders
dragged Hong Kong dong a dangerous
dangerous abyss and I'm joined now from
New York by shoe bang shoe there was a
student leader during the protests in
1989 in Tiananmen Square and formerly
one of the most wanted men in China
watching it closely and every level it's
following what happened in 1989 because
the government never responded
positively to what's the professor
demand so we have to isolate the way of
protest is really fluid and could
escalate to a level that I think you
know two completely different level I'm
riveted by it now and many of my friends
are watching closely obviously there is
a an agreement between the British and
the Chinese authorities for a protected
status for Hong Kong and special
freedoms for Hong Kong for 50 years
do you fear that the Chinese are
increasingly seeking to break that
agreement to me I think you see that
aspect and publishers being kidnapped
from Hong Kong and the
young people couldn't run for the
logistic position people all we want is
this direct election you know democracy
and they are denied two million people
on the street that's loud and clear the
government ignored it I think that's the
main issue now people's rights have been
denied for so long you know I was there
five years ago that umbrella revolution
all we wanted was direct the election of
the chief executive and they were
brutalized and many of the leaders in
prison now that's what today's protests
have seen and they realized they'd have
to there's no end to the detriment of
the freedom in hong kong for 50 years
people who say that babies were damaged
by a pregnancy testing drug have sought
justice and accountability from the
companies that produced it and from the
UK regulator tonight Sky News can reveal
that 200 of those parents are preparing
to sue the government and to drug firms
they say allowing the use of prima das
was negligent and put patients lives at
risk it's a major development in a
health scandal which left children with
life-changing difficulties sexual
relation not bad you're very bright
funny sense of humor obviously but it's
just people people don't take the time
to work that out
no shame at home and it's right know me
I'm on my own and I've never had
anything like me
have a relationship with Naomi had
children often wonder what if it hasn't
been frump in the girl know my mother by
now yeah I'm not quite thinking
recipients of the legal letters include
the UK government for failure to protect
patients and German pharmaceutical giant
Bayer who now own cheering the
manufacturer of the drug Bayer told Sky
News we believe this action to be
without merits and will defend our
position vigorously and if necessary in
court
[Music]
founder and chief executive of the
Chinese tech giant Parkway is talked
exclusively to Sky News telling us he's
confident a deal will be done with the
UK government that's despite America
urging his allies not to do business for
the company as a result of security
concerns
she designed can do so shanty Sanjay
solid design controller you know your
Cinque Cinque would you want watching
choosing a title a church or polish
supporter or machine she it's so poorly
person P so so cool focus still that I
should at the end I want to talk about
some of those u.s. concerns the
relationship between Huawei and the
perceived relationship between highway
and the Chinese state the first thing
the National Intelligence law in 2017
this law states that any organization in
citizens shall support and cooperate in
national intelligence work with the
Chinese state I mean that has been
caveated but why should we not just take
the law as it stands in black and white
okay you can see he knew you if I was so
on college's history so identical man
why would you say beta Y which I would
your poor time out on the hands and
since this crisis began the conflict
between the US and Huawei what
conversations have you had with the
Chinese leadership young would relay
push out through your heart
do you wonder would you somehow tell um
Rita tell humble - she won - well I
indeed she bought one day now why did
the digger since I'm doing now - but
silver piece of my y'all candy you can
make one now my we're just changing what
you're sensing honey
there has been a lot of intervention by
the Chinese government you know a bit of
pressure on States everywhere - except
my way is that sort of pressure from the
Chinese government helpful or unhelpful
you may look I saw to me lack of she
needs time Peter I'll just reach in Gina
you made good time me I was so fundo you
can watch Maya Mindy yippee Italy's yeah
totally you know why means only hazard
if a needy Chickasaw carpet ring ever
Niels Tovah we saw what you saw was so
tender but should I that's one minute
Bobby I've done that one quite soon we
shopping tonight so just to get it
straight to sum up the US government is
actually being helpful to Holloway while
the Chinese government is being
unhelpful to Holloway bullets Amish my
chances
a Russian opposition activist Liubov
soballe claims that she has been
detained by police as protests get
underway in Moscow for the fourth
consecutive weekend mr. Baugh who is an
ally of the Kremlin critic Alexei
Navalny
posted a video on social media showing
police entering her office to conduct a
search the police are here at the centre
where these collect signatures they're
going to break down the door I'm joined
now by marina Litvinenko she's the wife
of the former Russian FSB agent
Alexander who was murdered with
radioactive polonium back in 2006 for me
is very important sasha is not forgotten
and everything what he tried to achieve
but was not able because he was killed
it's now happened people started to
understand more and more what he tried
to do and my position just to help to do
this
but you can't go back to Russia I would
like to go back to Russia but every time
when I have this idea something happened
and now when we see all these actions
absolutely illegal just thinking people
to prison it makes me feel very unsafe
when you see those protests what does it
make you think is there any point I
think it's a very important message to
the West and you need to pay attention
and I think it's a test how the Western
governments will react if they decide is
just an ordinary protest or they will
finally understand Putin was not elected
as it's shown by majority of people in
Russia people tired for what happened in
Russia for 20 years and now we have
another very serious message security
service took control of Russia state my
husband in 1998 tried to send this
message what is a dangerous might be in
the future for Russia it was not taking
them nobody believed it when Sasha was
poisoned in 2006 and his last message he
said
butin might send one person but the
protests all around the world will be
state all-time during his life and now
we can see this and this is test for
Western governments how do you see an
end to the Putin regime ever coming
about it's a difficult I think not about
ending of Putin's regime I'm thinking
about of how is a civilian society
started to grow up in Russia it's never
happened before people were so passive
they didn't believe they might changed
anything and for my point of view this
is very serious sank Samsung going to be
changed in the northwest of the u.s.
state of Wyoming lies a patch of land
that's become the focus of a twenty
seven and a half million dollar project
called mission Jurassic the project
which is led by the Children's Museum of
Indianapolis has taken out a 20-year
lease on the land and is leading a dig
that has already produced tons of
dinosaur bones giving clues to life 150
million years ago we have some of the
most incredible dinosaur bones that I've
ever had the chance to play with in my
whole career ranging from the big long
neck long tail dinosaur the sauropods
which people are probably very familiar
with Diplodocus at the naturist Museum
in London which i think is now tour in
the UK but it sees kind of classic
Jurassic dinosaurs we're digging up here
in Wyoming what's so unique about
Wyoming when it comes to fossils why is
why there's so many there we're very
lucky here because we have the just-so
conditions for preserving dinosaurs but
also for having the correct age rocks up
at the surface so that it's this perfect
storm when you're looking to find
dinosaur fossils but what makes this
site so absolutely incredible dare I say
world-class is that it combines not only
the fossil bones of dinosaurs also there
trackways huge number of trackways but
also plants because if you ought to
paint a picture of what the Jurassic
period looked like some 150 million
years ago
you need some plant life so
this site has become one of the best
windows we can open on this moment in
time 20 years sounds like a long time
lots of hands on deck but are you
actually going to have enough time to
get everything that you want that's the
$64,000 question or should I say the
twenty seven point five million dollar
question we are throwing everything we
can into understanding as much as we can
about this particular site and the time
we have available and it's remarkable
that in this point in time the Jurassic
a period of global climate change
and seeing how life was reacting to that
climate change it's got some really
useful things that we can learn like
just impact us in the 21st century one
of three core services by plastic
bottled water can you believe it that's
according to new research out today
which also found more than half of
plastic either goes into landfill or
ends up in our oceans it's a issue very
close to our heart here at Sky and this
study has been done by Brita the actor
Joanna Lumley has been partnering with a
company to raise awareness of single-use
bottled water and it leaders I think
we've all seen the films and we've all
seen the plastic bottles in the water
and we've all seen that they don't
biodegrade and there's no getting rid of
them we buy so much drinking water in
plastic bottles and it seems absolutely
ridiculous because in this country we
have absolutely gorgeous clean tap water
lots of people say oh but I wouldn't
drink tap water because it may have
additives in it and I didn't really like
the taste of it that's why when it's
filtered it is literally fabulous so
tell us how have you changed your
lifestyle what habits have you changed
aside from obviously the filtered water
think what have you done to stop to
reduce your use of single-use plastic
this makes me sound like mrs. Springs
which I am I reuse cling film all the
time I reuse every kind of wrapping
everything you have everything that
comes in plastic I take it really
carefully the cellophane which you can't
at the moment recycle you do that
the other I always rinse it wash it and
put it for recycling you say what else
have I changed what I tell you if
somebody gives me let's say a takeaway
lunch which has little plastic spoons I
wash them and keep them because I'll
tell you one thing when actors are given
cups of coffee they never get given a
spoon but guess what I've got a plastic
spoon my bag which is Washington recycle
which I stir news and wash and put back
in my bag again so just be so careful
say to people do you need this plastic
couldn't you use metal or or like me a
pencil to stir your coffee what's wrong
with a pencil that's what I'm trying to
say don't use a borrow obviously did be
stupid
use a pencil
my mouth cannot write you a white flag
it will never be a Bible verse my mouth
cannot be shaped into the apology you
say both you and God deserve the
dominican-american slam poet Elizabeth
Acevedo made history this summer by
becoming the first ever writer of color
to win the UK's most prestigious
children's book award the Carnegie Medal
dates back to 1936 and previous winners
it included arthur ransome CS Lewis and
Neil Gaiman slam poetry is a fun name to
describe performance poetry or oral
poetry that is done on a stage and you
get a score card after so it's a poetry
competition the heart of it is just
sharing poetry out loud but we make it a
kind of a game by by assigning scores
and it also makes it more interesting
more relevant to younger people it's not
the same as sitting down reading some
poetry by Shakespeare and written in a
language that perhaps a lot of young
people don't identify with right I mean
it's it's poetry that's meant to be
embodied as most poetry is but you are
thinking about how do I manifest the
language what do I do with my hands how
do I connect and look at people and
create an experience in this space
together and I think young people are
really drawn to the honesty of it and
the vulnerability of it and you know the
competition how did you feel when you
when you found out that you you were the
first person of color to win the
Carnegie Medal I came to go to the
ceremony I didn't know what was going to
happen and the morning of someone told
me like by the way did you know that if
you were to win or or one of the other
authors of color one of you would be the
first and I was a bit astounded I mean
to be in a long lineage of so many
amazing writers of color right that I
really do consider myself someone who is
grabbing the baton and so know how many
people I revere it felt like such an
honor to be able to carry that in this
moment and also that moment of there are
so many people I love who probably
should have gotten this first yeah it's
a cross between making the hairs on the
back of your neck stand up and also
feeling a little bit disappointed right
right I mean it's a difficult it's a
difficult feeling to carry I'm so proud
I'm so proud but also just I
that a lot of these awards and prizes
rethink the way that they've done things
and the people they exclude when we
consider the Canon because we have you
know we've got people like manly
Blackmun who've been Children's Laureate
and we have big poets like Benjamin
Zephaniah who have been out there for
years and years it does seem astonishing
doesn't it but it hasn't happened before
right and maybe were happy now the man
soon to become one of the most
influential in world cricket has told
Sky News corruption and match-fixing
posed the biggest threat to the sport
the sri lankan Kumar Sangakkara about to
become the first non-british president
of the MCC says the game will die unless
corruption is eradicated it is without
doubt that the future of tetris is east
changing and there are a lot of factors
that have come into it and one is free
agency and franchise cricket the
spreading of the game of cricket across
borders that are not very familiar with
Test cricket not have the heritage and
tradition of quicker to actually have
tests with a take hold there have been
many changes made to try and hold on to
the current number of fans and
spectators that love the sport and also
to try and bring you bringing more and
more and new fans to the sport to make
it financially viable not just for the
country that have iconic series like
England Australia after the powerhouses
of course like India but for the entire
test-playing fraternity but do you fear
for the future of Test cricket well I
think the fears are justified and I
think maybe at certain times there will
have to be a change of mindset from
everyone concerned as to to what tests
wicked means Test cricket
kind of encompasses everything that is
beautiful and great about this sport
there is no doubt about it for us as
part of the MCC past players present
players administrators it is imperative
that we take the responsibility
seriously and we leave no stone unturned
in the future - to try and not just
safeguard the game but to make it really
relevant for people that played and to
refit I mean how do you prevent the
franchise is it one day cricket taking
over the game and effectively
limited-overs cricket whitewall cricket
becomes the sport I think we have to
introduce cricket or give kids as many
opportunities as we possibly can to get
into cricket at an early stage the key
is to get people playing early
understanding the pride that they have
in following either their county or
their national team but will they want
to play one day cricket rose and test
critizise Test cricket the thing that we
need to preserve well we can introduce
people to the short form then hopefully
they'll get the opposite bill don't like
it they'll enjoy it they'll understand
it and I want to graduate to the
ultimate form which is Kumar says is is
playing Test cricket for your country
corruption has been identified as an
match-fixing how much of a threat do you
think that is it is the biggest threat
to the integrity of the sport the trust
that the fans and spectators have in it
when it comes to commercial terms of
marketing and sponsors you want to watch
something you love and Trust is exactly
I mean what you see is basically it
should be what you get and I think there
has to be greater play awareness built
around this and players themselves
taking responsibility to actually say no
first of all and to be educated as to
what the reporting process is and what
the protocols in place trust needs to be
established between not just the ICC
anti-corruption needs but the home board
units that are in place at the same time
administrators being vetted selectors
coaches all of them need to buy into
this and to understand that if we do not
preserve the integrity of the game we
test cricket t20 cricket or any format
if the spectators don't trust it they're
not going to come they're not gonna fall
in love with it the passion
the game dies